[Musique]
c'est la fin idéale
j'accorde à son journal pour les
nouvelles j'espère qu'elles seront
sociaux tels voyages grande porte à la
base imam sur qu'outil des petits
commérages eu de très grands traits le
petit écho de la forêt il y à toutes les
informations à chaque nouvelle édition
on n'a jamais de déception ça vous le
découvrirez dans le tue des cours de
l'offre
[Musique]
[Rires]
voyons voyons que dit notre journal au
écouter certes les fans tel est pris qui
croyait prendre
hier il a fait très chaud et bien si je
me ferais le bon une petite sieste ou
tard elles ont vraiment dormir au moins
de temps qu'il ne faut pour dire des
bêtes ou battus tout ce que je sais
faire une bonne petite sieste imposé y a
rien d'autre à faire pour une telle
chaleur ils tous os dormir du sommeil du
juste mais même moselle de la cigogne
elle ne faisait pas la sienne dans ce
cas comment mais vous dormez si je ne
m'abuse
mais c'est abominable mais vous n'avez
pas honte
parce qu'alors l'avenue mythique quoi
excusez moi vous aurez le réveiller non
mais j'ai fait un cauchemar lequel j'ai
rêvé qu'on me volait mêlée tu sais ce
qui va vous arriver si vous dormez tout
le temps alors de boussac mais vous y la
cigogne bliss la malheureuse tosca à la
suivre dans la clairière regarder les
taux ce cas on dirait de bp mais on ne
dort pas en plein jour pourquoi parce
que ça ne se fait pas voilà pourquoi je
vais vite des billets ces deux paresseux
comment vous allez voir j -p
louis au travail voilà où nous vient de
faire un constat et pouvant table comme
si évident que je devrai travailler moi
aussi allonger le jour de bouddha mais
ça fait bon consommateur qui continuent
le mien aussi
rassurez-vous vous n'allez pas
travailler bon alors on peut se
rendormir
nous nous nous allons jouer jouer croix
est là pour quoi pour vous empêcher de
dormir en plein après midi nous allons
jouer à cache-cache comme quand nous
étions bobin nous allons rire faisant
contre mauvaise fortune bon coeur
luigi pitot ce cas dur à accepter de
jouer à cache-cache 7 8 9 et 10
attention givet cacher ou non je saurai
vous trouvez
je vais vous découvrir où sont ils mais
où sont ils
notre bonne cigognes avait beau chercher
elle ne trouvait pas ses camarades de
jeu si on ne les trouve pas c'est
vraiment ridicule
tosca jp louis avait trouvé une astuce
pour échapper aux jeux obligatoire que
leur avait imposé cette cigogne est
collé collé ses gongs l'intégrer dans
les forêts éco recours légaux de sico
diatribe
est-ce que vois-je pour chanter au lieu
de jouer et on est mieux mourir que de
hors jeu cache cache très dumoutier
krimo des incroyables
quand je pense que j'ai fini km pour
vous trouver égal on est dedans et vit à
londres amusé ou que nous sommes refusés
je n'en suis plus bas et forêts à vire
mademoiselle je suis épuisé ma voiture
je crois que je vais faire une petite
sieste une sieste voir et pas le droit
et et y est crédit baudier je mens ma
seconde
allez on dit de battre nous voulions
jouer l'école
quelle horreur ouais bon j'ai fait un
cauchemar abominable cru que vous
vouliez jouer à cache cache
mais oui mais oui mademoiselle de la
cigogne a été prise à son propre piège
il ne faut jamais imposé aux autres que
je voudrais pas faire soi même n'est ce
pas faire téléphone à bientôt pour une
prochaine édition du petit etc ou de la
forêt
[Musique]